here's our intro
[Music]
hello everybody this is grandmaster
varacobian and i'm back after
after a while and i'm glad to be back
doing this
end game lecture tonight with you insane
in the end game
and i will be showing you one of my
games played actually a couple of days
ago at the saint louis chess club this
was a tournament called
america's qualifier for the world cup
i had a pretty good run in it and it
came very very close to qualify
in that tournament but anyway i want to
show you this game
and then ask you to find the ideas okay
so this game i'm playing against
grandmaster perez
from cuba so we're going to be focusing
more on the end game but i will show you
the entire game okay
c4 d4 d5 c4 c6 at the moment we have
a slav defense opening and i have been
playing the exchange violation for a
long time
you can tell probably from my older
lectures so we take
take and we enter the exchange violation
of the slav
knight c3 knight f6 knight f3
knight c6 bishop f4 and now he played a6
idea behind this move is to wait and if
white plays for example e3 which looks
tempting there is a bishop g4 move
pinning pinning the knight and
it's it's it helps block to equalize the
game something like this
and bishop d6 so that's why you have to
play a little bit more careful okay
you have to be a little bit more careful
here you can't just play e3
now i play rook ace rook c1 first
bishop f5 because bishop g4 is not very
effective here because i have knight e5
so here i play e3
e6 queen b3 putting pressure
rook a7 again i kind of gonna go a
little bit fast in opening this is still
theory and then
i'm gonna start focusing more when we
reach the end game position because
today's topic
is about endgames so and when you get a
position like this
uh it's normally slightly better for
white because
i have a little bit of a leading
development and also this
squares c5 and b6 are weakened and
that's why you play the move knight a4
to try to control these two squares okay
so now he plays bishop g4 it's a very
good move pinning my
knight and trying to uh exchange him at
some point
uh by the way if you were thinking oh
why he didn't play knight a5 it looks
like a natural good move if he does it's
actually a very strong move
queen to b6 and now we are going to see
the strength of this move because now in
the
exchange occurs knight is going to be
sitting on b6
very very powerful and now this rook
cannot go anywhere okay
the rook simply cannot go anywhere so
it's just a
difficult position for black so
uh that's why my opponent played bishop
g4 here
and i decided to play uh
h3 by the way later on after the game i
started shaking and then i realized
young jeffrey shang had a game like this
actually he played
in fact two games in this position
against another grand master
so jeffrey has been playing this
position as well so now he played
black played very well here i thought
because he didn't just sit there
passively he played here
attacking the knight and now knight c5
thank you everybody great to see you all
great to see you all after a long time
so i hope you will enjoy this this
this lecture so now he played b5
knight takes c5 and now gran master
perez plays
e5 breaking the center okay
he plays e5 and breaking the center
and now i need to do something to
proclaim
the chord because i do not want to take
only five because if i take on e5 then
he plays knight d5
putting pressure on the bishop and then
he's going to put the knight on c4 i
didn't i didn't want to allow this
because now it's going to be very
difficult
to do anything here okay
so that's why he plays i play queen c3
and now just to keep it under control he
takes takes
rook c8 uh i have a nice advantage here
computer loves my position and gives a
pretty good size advantage here for
white because
the knight is strong on c5 there are
some weaknesses on a6
i played g3 and
it's a novelty actually but
maybe not the best move here the better
move here would have been rook c2
to get ready to bring this rook into the
game to triple up
to triple up on this critical c
file okay that would have been a more
direct idea
but i played g3 kind of a prophylactic
idea to control f4 at some point maybe
even play king g2
so now i play g6 i play queen d2
moving my queen away so i can start
doubling up but here my opponent had a
very strong move
and that was would have been rook ac7
this perhaps
could have given him the equalizer
because now he's threatening to take on
d4 so for example if i go here
he goes knight takes d4 i take back
he plays rook c5 rook takes c5
and now things are
uh even though he's up upon it's just
probably just equal here okay
so all right so now uh
this was the critical moment he had to
play rook ac7 to attack
why is a c file more critical than e
file because
i my knight is on c5 great wolf question
from great wolf
rook and there is action on c file the
knight on c5 is established that's why
it needs to try to dislodge the knight
okay on e file is just the empty file
there is not much going on there
but of course you cannot you can say
wait a minute what about the move b4
we can play b4 perhaps to cement the
position of that knight but if we do
that then
he has this 94 move come in activating
i take take bishop takes
and now he just trades we have to trade
everything
and it's just equality here
okay
rook ac7 knight
knight a6
yeah if you play knight a6 here that
will run into knight takes d4
actually and actually the problem is
your f3
and if you take here no no no i'm not
taking your uh
knight here i'm taking your rook on c1
okay
okay that's why i'm taking your rook on
sivan
uh okay answering the question of a deal
here okay so that's the problem you need
to be
focused okay you need to be focused on
that not to blunder a tactic
he's not he's not plotting just to take
back there okay
so that's why it takes
um so this was a very very strong move
rook
ac7 but he didn't do that he played rook
e8
that gave me an opportunity to try to
bring my rook into the game
some exchanges occur it looks position
fairly balanced
but now i play the interesting move
queen to c3
again uh trying to create some ideas
with the knight
a6 when was this game played this game
was played
uh 24th of this month uh last month
sorry about a week ago
okay so now queen c3 i'm putting
pressure and he started to think a lot i
realized he wasn't feeling very
comfortable now
after this so of course he played b4
here
but if he plays knight e4
my question to you is what should i play
here
okay what is my correct move here hello
hello
everybody hello theo now what is the
idea
very strong move here because if you
take on e4
he takes back with the pawn
because we're putting pressure on the c
file that's why we put the queen on c3
so we can try to attack on a c file well
if you do bishop takes then pawn takes
like you can do this this
and i can even just take on d4 here for
example but the correct move is
correct joseph stern yes knight b7
excellent move hitting the queen despite
our queen being under attack we attack
his queen
and now he takes and we simply capture
knight to d6 and now look at that
everything now is hanging
on the c file here okay so that's a
that's a nice tactic by joseph here
perfect that's what i was trying
to do and if he takes back now then he's
got some problems here guys
i got a c file i got some weaknesses to
work with here on a6 so
he's far away here far away from
equality here okay
he has to work very very hard to get
that half a point here
so knight b7 is a beautiful tactic okay
because your queen is being under attack
but you ignore that and you play the
knight b7
instead so my opponent didn't like that
idea so he decided to play b4
immediately to try to
kick my queen away which i did i play
queen d3
and now he played knight e4 so far he's
been playing pretty sharp and accurately
and now i'm picking five and here he
makes an error
here he should have just continue
playing a5
to move that pawn away from hanging and
then protect his b4 pawn
and position is maybe very very slightly
better for me but i think
good chances for him to equalize
okay but instead he played the
queen f6 and this is a mistake
because now i take he takes
i take he takes knight d4 so we get to
this position but here
since he's put he's got some loose pawns
and his knight is not very stable
here i can try to win the pawn
how how we can try to win the pawn in
this position
please type your answers how can we win
the pawn here
we need to get some pawn advantage here
so we can try to
convert vivek no not rook c6 vivek
knight will take back vivek
absolutely rook c4 there we go now we're
seeing some correct answers here
very nice rook c4 attacking this
attacking this this is why he had to
play the move a5
he had to play the move a5 it was very
very important okay
so rook c4 i felt comfortable now
because now
if he plays rook d7 trying to keep the
knight there no problem
i take and now he cannot even move his
knight because his rook is hanging
okay on d7 so it's just the extra pawn
he played knight e6
and now for example if you think oh wait
a minute what if he plays knight c5
check
now here and threatening
queen f8 mate and also queen h8
so very very strong position for white
here he does not have time
to take okay yes this is from world cup
qualifier
yes so um
he decided to play h5 a
very strong practical move because he's
trying to
uh he's trying to make things
complicated he's got some h4 ideas
and i played bishop d5 in this position
a computer prefers the move h4
but the reason i declined this move
because i thought this is tricky knight
c5
now if i check he goes king h7
and if i go back to b8 he can just take
because now i just have a check
and he's got an escape area queen h8 he
just trades
okay so i probably just have to give a
draw here check he cannot go back
because i take the rook
so he will go here and i have to be with
perpetual
but actually i have a much better idea
if he goes king f7
all i got to do is just go here bishop
f3
just drop it back because he doesn't
have any any good ideas here because
knight d3 doesn't work i have queen
takes d3
and now i have the rook b8 idea still
uh you know threatening there okay
so this is a very very nice advantage
for me
but i wanted to centralize my bishop and
kind of get my rook into the game but
now he plays
h4 trying to complicate the matters and
here i played
a move that i liked but maybe i could
have done something better here
so let's see here first of all let's
pause here and see if we can find the
best continuation here
how should white continue here
because there is a trap here if we take
joseph he has this trick
take and look at that fork okay
and now he's taking advantage of it okay
okay thank you thank you vinayak
all right now after h4 what do we do
yeah well that's the thing he's a tricky
grandmaster he's trying to set up some
tactics okay
he is not going to go down without a
fight okay
so what do we do
queen f3 chess king and that's what i
played actually
i played queen f3 which is a good move
but there is
another possibility here ahead i saw
this move but i didn't go for it because
i thought it was just too complicated
what is the other idea
bishop e6 yeah bishop b6
if he takes back i just go rook takes h4
i'm up two pounds
now he takes and now i have this idea
bishop takes f7 check
rook takes f7
queen takes g3
i i thought that this was very good for
me but again i was
you know thinking maybe he he will have
some activity but okay with accurate
play
i should be able to convert this
position into a win no problem
okay so computer prefers this way a
little bit better but
for me it was more important to trade
the queens that's why i played queen f3
and now he he doesn't have anything
better than to trade because otherwise
he's losing another pound so now we
enter the end game a favorable end game
for me no question i'm up upon but still
i have to show some technique
okay some good technique here now he
plays check
and now from here on i want you to
control all the moves
and find next six 17 correct moves here
to
get the victory so let's see here what
do you think i should do here guys
my king is under attack my h3 pawn is
hanging
it seems like he's getting some kind of
counter play
maybe a little bit of a counter play but
a counter play okay
so what should i do now with my king
king g4 absolutely we need to activate
the king and put pressure
now he takes now i have two options here
how should i capture back here
again having the bishop versus knight is
usually an advantage in this type of
positions because
bishop is stronger when you're fighting
on two sides of the board okay
okay
now what do we do here pawn takes
many people want to take back with the
pawn
well i have those two options take with
the pawn or take
connecting
yeah i i well if you take with the pawn
you connect your pawns but your king
still remains in a little bit of danger
okay
so that was the only reason i took with
the king because now things are more
safe here for me but i agree taking with
the pond would have been good too
okay sorry guys uh now i took back with
the king
and now he plays rook here rook d7
questioning my bishop okay
now i go here bishop c4
putting pressure on a6
thank you and now he plays a5
tricky move here he's trying to get some
kind of he
he managed to remove my bishop from
there okay
oh why not king takes g5 it's a
possibility but it's
not a very good one he has check and
takes
and you know he he has better chances in
rook end games
rook end games he has better drawing
chances than anything else
okay so i don't want to go to the rook
end games because of that
now he goes here now the question is
what should i do
where should i put my bishop
now what do we do here where do we put
the rook
hello hello helen hello allen hello
so what do we do guys where do we put
the rook
i want to put it i want to make sure i'm
protecting my bishop
okay so this is very important i want to
protect the bishop
guess i sneezed too loud yeah guys all
right
hello hello welcome everybody welcome
everybody good to see you all
good to see you all here so the question
is where do we put this rook okay
this rook is under attack here but like
i say i want to put it somewhere stable
okay
rook p8 he goes king g7 tail
rook a4 correct rook a4 absolutely
correct
protecting the bishop attacking okay
now he plays check so i don't want to go
to g2 because some rook d2 ideas so i
have to attack him and
here he had to realize that the best
chance he has
best chance he has is to go to the rook
end game it looks very tough
but this would have been his best chance
okay
this position got it
so that's the idea if 92 just king e3
but he played 96 he wanted to keep the
knight here and try to do some tricky
stuff but
it's not going to work here now let's
try to
cut the squares of that knight okay
let's try to cut the squares for that
night guys
thank you thank you mind appreciate the
compliment
so what do we do now bishop d3 yeah we
can play bishop d3 but then he will go
knight b7 you know
i kind of want a little bit more out of
the position guys bishop
bishop d3 he has knight b7
and it's it's good winning chances it's
not trivial winning but it's a good
winning chances
rensmere bishop d3 i'm not sure guys
bishop
you're saying bishop d3 but what do you
do against this
and don't play this don't fall for this
track dick guys
see you're walking into some trouble now
with this
and he's got the four key here okay so
let's not
get into this okay but okay that
position is still unclear maybe i'm
still better there because i'm winning
the a pawn
but anyway let's try to put our bishop
to better squares
to more centralized square correct
christopher of course bishop needs to be
on d5
absolutely because that's guarding this
square guarding this guarding this
and putting pressure on this and now we
are threatening to take this pawn
if he tries to defend passively this is
not going to work for him because what
do we do
if he tries to defend possibly what do
we do here guys
absolutely absolutely we play b4
and we put pressure here okay absolutely
he played knight b5 trying to get some
activities
and now another very important moment
here because if again he's keep
trying to trick me like i go here he
wants to trick me with this
so but it's not going to work because
i'm going to calculate everything
accurately okay i'm going to calculate
everything accurately
now what do we do no come on guys not
bishop c6
now what do we do here we need to defend
our bishop amit
amid king e4 yes that's correct
centralizing the king
protecting that bishop there and still
threatening to take the pawn okay
now he plays 96 shaq giving check to my
queen now what do i do now
again we need to continue play actively
okay
we don't slow down we continue to play
actively
absolutely king e5 now he goes king g7
because he
and now he can't do anything else and
originally
originally i was gonna take the pawn on
a5 but
just win the pawn but but remember
i always mentioned this in my lectures
when you see a good move
you look for a better one okay and i
didn't rush here
i looked for a better one to get into a
more
uh simple winning position rook takes a5
is winning no question
but there is a way for you here to force
the exchange of the rooks
and once you force the exchange of the
rooks the victory
is going to be trivial okay so there is
a force way for you to trade
rook search i know k5 is good
rookie 5 is good i agree with you but
let's try to figure out a way to
trade it don't rush absolutely take your
time
but find the best continuation to force
the exchange of the rooks
once you exchange the rooks victory is
trivial
how can we do that bishop c6 all right
hitting the rook
rook d8 by my opponent
and now
and now absolutely
absolutely guys i see some great answers
rook d4 pin it to win it
and now the knight cannot move anywhere
now he's pinned
so he has to play only move f6 and now
look at that journey of that king it
started all the way here
on g2 look at the journey of the king
where is that king going huh
the journey continues right
to where where is that journey continue
of course e6 now we're threatening rook
takes d6 picking up that knight
now he plays knight f7 and now we
accomplish exactly what we wanted it
the swap of the rooks and now
where do we go with the king now here
what do you think what's the best square
for the king
correct correct king is six absolutely
now
i have few options here which one is the
correct one
king d6 absolutely
he goes check his only chance is to try
to activate his knight
to create some ideas with it
now what do we do
no we we need to try to get to the a
pawn here guys remember
we're trying to get to the a pawn so
king c5 correct now he goes here now he
wants to get active now
knight d3 is something so now you need
to make a good move here
to cut the squares of the knight which
move you're gonna play to cut the
squares of the knight okay so the king
is simply cut off
so which squares you're gonna play to
have the king cut off
bishop b5 absolutely vinayak
very nice move because we take away the
squares of the knight boom
we take away squares of the knight so he
has only one square on f3
it's a nice cut bishop b4 is not as nice
because bishop f5 is going to allow this
and then king comes in
okay so that's why you want to do the
bishop b5 cut
now he plays a5
and now what is the best way to win this
position
of course i can try to go king b6 king
a5 but that takes me too long
and it's it's winning though no question
about that it's winning but then
i have to deal with him playing
something like this
if i take knight c4 it's still winning
but i don't need to do that
there is something cleaner i can do in
this position okay
what can i do something cleaner here
no b4 he takes i don't know about b4
i don't want to play b4 right now
f4 f4 is a possibility as well
but again my main thing is to try to fix
this pawn okay
if i can fix that a pawn that a pawn can
never move
okay so that's what i'm trying to
achieve guys i'm trying to fix the pawn
so he cannot go anywhere
a4 absolutely a4 fixing
okay now he plays f4
and now how we are going to force
the resignation here in two more moves
yeah king b6 is good king b6 king a5 but
i didn't want to spend
too much time on that okay i wanted to
go directly
i wanted it to go directly okay
b4 absolutely guys absolutely before
let's be more direct okay in our play
so absolutely before now it takes
and we take back with the king so he
doesn't push this anywhere
and now play a5 a6 a7
and he cannot do anything okay
and here he decided to resign because
first of all his king is not in a square
and he cannot stop it okay
so the king cannot stop it any other way
he can try to stop it
is he has to try to bring the knight in
like this
like this and go here but my plan was
just to go here
bishop d7 force him to the if he goes
away then we just promote
if he goes here i just go here and win
this
okay and here we can just go bishop g4
and that's why my opponent resigned
after the plan of before
because he realized there are absolutely
no chances okay
so this was a important win because this
victory
qualified me for the next round in a
round number three
of the same tournament okay all right so
this end game was
example of you a domination okay
we witnessed the domination of the night
in general
knight vs bishop okay domination of the
knight
versus bishop when there are pawns on
both sides of the board remember when
there are pawns on two sides of the
board
then bishop is stronger than knight if
there is fight on one side of the board
then the roles are changing then in that
case
the knight is a better piece okay i have
played knight each yes i've played them
before a few times
so so remember that okay when they're
fight on two flanks
then you have this idea to remember
all right great to see you guys we're
gonna do one more puzzle
before we finish for today i will have
more end game stuff for you for next
week okay
so but okay hope you enjoyed this this
game so let me save this
and we're going to set up a
position
and do a very nice in-game position okay
okay black to move
in this position okay black to move in
this position and
what is the evaluation of this end game
okay
is this winning or this is due thank you
thank you i'm glad you enjoyed the
lecture guys
um uh i'm my favorite grandmaster
i don't know i studied carpool games so
i would say caspar carpool petrossian
so i studied a lot of carpool all right
guys at the end we're going to do this
wonderful end game position
where the knowledge knowledge of the
position is going to help you win
is this a win for black or this is a
draw
don't rush if you answer this correctly
you need to give me the line okay
is this a win or a draw
is this a win or a draw guys
yes i have played against carlson few
times
this is a draw no no i think let's think
let's think let's think you need to have
a plan we can't just say it's a win or a
draw we need to have a plan
black wins with a zuksavang okay
win easily okay so what do you suggest
to do then if it's vin is easily
so where do we go now with the king
okay where do we go now with the king
guys
we can go to f5 yes i have played
vichyanan also yes
okay vinayak how you win this you say
it's mean easily
king f5 i don't know king f5 you're
already stepping away
king f5 he goes here how's this a win
because you know you only have one pawn
if i trade that pawn you're not winning
this game
okay so you can't do that first of all
you're checked
you're under a check take us you need to
figure out where you're going to put
that king first
because your check tahas
aha now you're thinking correctly okay
you go here
now he pins you now he pins you back
okay now continue with the line you say
it's a win but continue with the line
what is the correct solution here
he can come forward he's going to check
you
and i see some correct answers here
yeah you can maybe play king c4 but
better
rook takes f2 let's not waste any more
time let's get to the winning
king and pawn end game guys he takes
we take he takes and now you're gonna do
something called
the this diagonal diagonal opposition
here
absolutely te has king d4 now this is
called
diagonal opposition if he goes away to
g2 then you go k3 now he goes on e2
now you switch to a regular opposition
here
okay
he goes here
king d3
and now we start using the shouldering
idea right
we are using the shouldering method to
push him away from his pawn
and now when he goes here he gets the
opposition on you
what is the correct move here what is
the absolute correct move here
you have to play
what is the absolute correct move here
because if you don't put your king on a
correct square here
you're not winning this game okay you
still need to put it on a correct square
here yes
king h3 exactly because you want to open
the door for him to get out of the
corner
you don't want to lock him in a corner
because if you go here
that's a mistake because he goes here
and guess what you just
draw the game you just draw the game
because of the opposition
and a still mate here if you come up
here guess what you just still made your
opponent okay
so that's why you go king h3
and now he goes here
we push we push we go
up and then we promote
and win okay so again the knowledge of
king and pawn end game is
instrumental so you will know from which
position to which you should trade
and get in order to win okay you have to
know your
uh king and pawn and games
yeah black can still correct a mistake
even if he doesn't do it immediately
correct great wolf
all right so again so very important to
remember that okay
king d5 rook d2
and king here uh retired from chess
or you'll see retired from
playing chess or from doing what no i'm
still working i'm not retired
but no i haven't i have i haven't
stopped playing chess yet i'm still
playing
anyway guys so that's that's it for
tonight
and once again we shoulder him in the
corner
and promote okay so remember this
important to know your kingdom pawn end
games okay
very very important okay guys no
i'm i'm not retired but i don't play
that much i play maybe four tournaments
a year
i'm i have many students so i teach and
i do a lot of work for the chess club so
and a few other things so yeah only play
maybe about four tournaments a year
but anyway great to see you everybody
here
i'll be back on thursday i believe we
have two lectures on youtube
and we're gonna have some fun on
thursday so make sure you guys all tune
in
okay all the students all over the world
so we'll we will see you on thursday
okay and
uh thank you everybody for the active
participation for your comments and
questions
and uh i will be back on thursday for
not
one two lectures okay to make sure you
tune in for thursday
lectures okay all right everybody have a
good day have a good
evening see you on thursday bye
you